bootleg cab podcast special guest in
here my guy price yes sir formerly known
as price tag yeah currently known as
just price yes sir my guy's been out
here burning up all kinds of [__]
freestyles and [__] come on I was like
where are you guys it's about time you
gotta run it back yes sir in a couple of
years since you came on the show and did
what you do man uh what do you got going
on real quick oh man we got a lot of
[__] I'm dropping the tape
um February 17th okay got a lot of the
homies on there some special [__] it's
like the day before Michael Jordan's
birthday
yeah I didn't know that that's pretty
dope it sounds like February 18th it's
Jordan's birthday that's fine yeah yeah
we got a perique on there RJ on there
Jay why are they on there Rayvon on
there no no near cars on there so much
thank you on there yeah you got the car
on there okay
my boy brands on there we stepping that
sounds great I'm sagging bro my Motown
dude I did my Moto for you over politics
tomorrow okay well listen man let's get
to the rapping we got price in here he's
one of the coldest out the city west
coast even though he ain't from the city
he's from the I.E but you know that's
not there yeah we're putting on for
everything west west side let's get to
it baby yeah
oh [__] hey
well hey Kev Happy New Year bro yes sir
happy New Year long time straight up man
we like 10 years 10 years plus
plus sure
you didn't see any [__] grow up in this
rap [__] I feel like man
for real but [__] just get started
let's get it we're gonna crack it up
look
my how the boys grown I used to have a
boost and that's why clap calling my
phone in America the little white boy
get promised a head start while the
black boy just get promised The
Headstone and that's only if the
GoFundMe go dummy [__] we ain't got life
insurance and my man got the money code
game and the big homies ain't do nothing
but treat us like Shaq coming down the
court all they told us to do was bang
it's 99 attributes all over my depth
chart plus I walked in here with animals
no PetSmart they hate to see me winning
I got them covering their eyes like the
kids gotta do in the movie showing the
sex Parts I'm still scaring the kids
Reptar fine after line after line
stretch marks I hear these rappers
sitting on rappers with nice chains but
truth is they dragging it cause it's out
of their price range did that make them
mad no animal cruelty but [__] the cats
out the bag hold on y'all remind me of
Eric hold a real shitty vibe that you're
holding we should compare these rappers
to lounge chairs how they folding y'all
should compare me Deluxe the way I'm
loading up bar after bar it's like a
Penitentiary here Derek Sullivan got
charged in true color star showing
that's why the black women Mary won't be
nothing like Candace Owens let's put
that on the record speaking of only
records these new rappers coming up
shorter than Gary Coleman gestures way I
told my girl this Glock and God gonna
protect us I ain't [__] will hoes all
out in the neck I feel like diamonds
should pop out this should pressure
while I use these Cartier frames as a
[__] boy detector like I see you I
heard your real [__] membership need to
get renewed or Nick from together mama
bought all that games previews I'm on
this Clips beat but this [__] just a
preview you know Clips preview uh make
movies when I need to I'm playing the
evils by Hove I'm eating Seafood I'm
with Second Street so I see more twos
than preschool I'm with the Seas but
don't think I'll be food let me get some
more we all man I'm Gonna Keep it
cracking look it's 20 23 gonna crack it
off
hello hey who had the last raspy flow
that could go probably kiss when the
last time you heard it like this
probably Clips bootle Kev I better be on
your next [__] list overalls
jumpsuits watch out [__] body this top
spinning calm down Dior jump series I
can't just shut the block down
black lives matter did all that marching
just for 2022 to come and all the people
be shot down by cops wow it's
mind-blowing flooded out my rolling like
where the time going I did everything in
this rap Dam except get a Grammy which
reminds me I got plaques I still gotta
order for Brandy all right Peter Monty
Sandy and Willie Dandy on the West Side
while they're implants Stanley I make
them all fall to their knees they can't
stand me while the government trying to
tell us who could take a plan B double
whammy high god with the family Dub with
the bag I have my back against the wall
like kids in trouble in class but still
getting cash ready for the draw come you
change your outlook I guarantee you'll
change your outcome is price yo get
price we sagging
new uh project what's it called February
17th no sleep in the city no sleep in
the city man we sagging man and I'm
stepping all year I'm telling y'all man
listen I ain't letting [__] breathe oh
well how can we buy all the great
colored merch that you uh clrd ent.com
and we lacing you with the pack man we
bring you the book and everything you
know I dropped the book
was that last year generational cures is
it acceptable for a white person to wear
a sweater that says colored most
definitely because colored is that's why
it's multiple colors in the logo ain't
just I just gotta make sure I don't know
man it ain't just all black and Anderson
what the [__] are you wearing bro man
that's what color about we start the
brand to create true Unity for pulling
up man thank you February 17th get the
new project hey what up y'all appreciate
you guys watching this week's freestyle
we're dropping another one next week and
sometimes we drop more than one in a
week but they're always brought to you
by LRG baby that's right loving me some
LRG always and right now if you go to
the website
l-r-g.com and you use the promo code
bootleg you're gonna get 30 off 30 off
that's almost half okay
at checkout that's right all right shout
out to LRG one more time L Dash R Dash
g.com and when you check out use that
promo code bootleg and save 30 off the
freestyles we'll be back next week
always brought to you by LRG baby